obviously game of thrones it's such a
huge fighty show but you didn't really
get to do any of the fighting no
early on uh when they realized um that
he shouldn't fight they attempted to
make me into one of those fighter guys
and uh
so i was out in the battle with an axe
and uh
chopped a guy's leg off
the gentleman whose leg i chopped off
was um god bless him a an amputee
so
i knew he was about probably about 70
years old so the one man i did kill
early on in the show was about a 70 year
old amputee so that's not very heroic
in my opinion
that's not a great day at work no
shooting your father spoiler alert uh on
the toilet
again not very heroic
and somehow people still like the
character so
yeah
they did i mean
i can imagine how lovely having that
paycheck for what i mean 10 years but
was it
was it nice
but was it was in any way a relief when
it finally came to an end yeah
yes i mean it's time to move on as hard
as it is that's the tricky thing about i
mean that's what we do for we go off for
a couple months and we have great
friendships and then you don't see each
other again and that one was a family
because we i lived in ireland basically
and it wasn't just the show it was the
life i had children there
um my daughter had an irish accent
affected
irish
totally affected um but truly we at my
feet were just in belfast the community
up there is so beautiful and yeah made
so many good friends so it was more for
me
just the life rather than the show
itself yeah um so that's really the
hardest thing to walk away from
[Music]
you